what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today guys looks like
we are finally getting joker 2 the
follow-up to the walking phoenix todd
phillips directed movie 44 oscar
nominations that previous one got one of
the highest grossing rated moves of all
time is it the highest or one of yeah so
with that in mind you know like they're
talking about how they're aiming for
like a 2023 shoot time and then so we
probably get a release this movie around
2024 to 2025 so the script is still in
early development stages there was a
part of me that always wondered whether
or not this movie would actually come
true it seemed like this would be a good
standalone movie and knowing that todd
phillips and joaquin phoenix were both
really insistent on not having this
joker cross paths with batman to keep it
very character focused on arthur fleck
seemed like the story might have been
done for them to return gives me hope
that they are developing a story that
has to be worthwhile for them to
actually return or it's just money i
can't turn down that boatload of chaos
and i had the second highest rated movie
too yeah exactly so with that in mind of
course there are not a lot of plot
details out there but there are rumors
about lady gaga possibly joining the
cast so i do want to talk about what
that role could possibly be a little bit
later but first what i wanted to dive
into is an idea that i've had for what
they could do for joker 2 for quite a
while i've had it for a few years in
fact i was a guest star like a few years
ago on movie fights screen junkies and
one of the questions was what would you
do for a joker too and that was actually
one of the easiest questions i've ever
had because i'm like i knew i know
exactly what i would want to do for a
joke or two so i kind of wanted to share
that pitch with you guys talk about it a
little bit because you know they're in
the early draft stages so you know todd
phillips if you guys are listening you
kind of like where i'm going with this
you know you need some rewrites feel
free to feel free to just steal
something i don't care just still steal
it and i just want to see it come true
i've had this log line written down
forever just the log line so i just want
to read it my basic pitch for this would
be after becoming a celebrity worship
serial killer receiving fan letters and
arkham and such the absentee leader of
the cult breaks arthur fleck out to lead
their cause but they find a difference
in ideologies they perceive from arthur
versus arthur's actual motives i call
this the cult of joker because if you
look at the events what happened in the
movie joker he had his own personal
agenda with the kills that he did those
people he killed on the subway the cult
following though the ones that started
all the riots and such the ones that
worshiped him at the very end their
ideas are focused more on the one
percent and the corruption the
capitalism the politicians they pretty
much misinterpreted his actions in that
movie as being something more profound
on the talk show with robert de niro he
directly says i'm not political he
doesn't have an agenda in that movie did
this to start a movement to become a
symbol do i look like the kind of clown
that could start a movement i killed
those guys because they were awful his
personal motives though when he did kill
they gave credence to these riots and so
what i imagine is that in this like cult
following not everyone in that group is
an unhinged mentally ill person like
arthur per se but they still interpreted
him as sort of a robin hood fighting
against the evil men in power right
that's why they loved him so much so
what happens when you break that person
out this way you can segue arthur
reflect because he doesn't fully arc
into the joker that we sort of expect
yes is he delusional is he a little bit
psychopathic sure but he doesn't become
the criminal mastermind in that film
which is what the joker is a criminal
mastermind still an unhinged anarchist
so you could segue from him being who he
was in arkham by the end of that movie
into becoming a criminal leader criminal
mastermind because by the end of joker 1
he receives this love and validation
from the people at the end of joker but
in this sequel instead of like revolting
to lead the people in poverty the people
who are angry with the one percent at
gotham you find out he actually doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that like he doesn't
care about them he never did you know
makes sense you watch this mentally ill
unstable man evolve into the master
manipulator the criminal mastermind the
selfish thief in the underworld of
gotham bringing anarchy to the streets
keep the joker isms but maintain the
themes of the first joker movie not just
put batman in here
no i feel like that would cheapen
everything and you could do yeah so much
more interesting work with just the
psychological yeah motivations of arthur
fleck and how it affects the world
around him and the fact that he is
coming from such a place of isolation
and probably a lot of people who do
follow him now are probably the kinds of
people he would not get along with
exactly so like what if by the end of
the journey the ones who ultimately
loved him who he found acceptance
through ultimately abandoned him his
symbol is stripped away and he becomes a
villain feared by the people of gotham
goes from pure psychopath into criminal
mastermind i think that could be like
kind of the midpoint of the film
actually it could be a breaking act too
sure but we're hearing these rumors
about lady gaga now as much as i've been
like i don't know about batman coming in
here i i know some people want that but
i don't i don't think so i feel like
todd phillips and walking phoenix were
never truly interested in it and in a
lot of ways i feel like even for someone
like myself who highly recommends joker
some of the bruce wayne stuff felt a
little bit like and we really need it
like thomas wayne felt necessary but
bruce do we really need that
man stick his hands in your mouth
when we're looking at who lady gaga
might be i'm not opposed to the idea of
her actually being harlene quinzel in
arkham asylum because we haven't gotten
the movie yet that really allows you to
deep dive in to him
manipulating harleen quinzel into
becoming harley quinn does she even need
to go full arc in that terrain no but
you can if you watch like lady gaga and
even american horror story like american
horror story hotel i know she's in
roanoke but that doesn't mean let's
get's going like more for a hotel but
you've seen her do like a star wars
morning she's got a lot of praise for
house of gucci she would bring something
very different a different flavor that i
think could match what joaquin phoenix
was doing with his more realistic
grounded interpretation of the character
and we could actually
see their relationship really develop
from psychologist to patient really see
how that forms and how ultimately the
patient ends up taking control of the
psychologist lady gaga would actually be
a great fit for that i don't think she
needs to become like harley quinn by the
end but it would be a cool character to
just have her be the doctor in that film
oh yeah i think that would be part of
the charm because the original it would
suit the original joker's rise to the
point where yeah maybe by the end she
does have some kind of break but you're
not going into full super villainy
territory and two i mean i feel like the
first movie is such a character study of
one person you could do the folia do
then in the second movie and yeah see
what happens when that person maybe
connects legitimately to somebody
because you could get a lot of confusing
feelings coming out of arthur fleck but
then also that tragic manipulation of
harleen quinzel of the one person trying
to give him the benefit of the doubt
maybe or at least getting through to him
a little bit you know like i feel like
there are a lot of very big and broad
ways a joker two could go but that feels
like a really nicely uh honed in and
contained way of
exploring just as twisted personal
territory yeah so that way you keep it
criminal focused you still keep it
within the tone and the themes of the
first one and then you could get a
little harley quinn easter egg in there
too but i don't know i mean they already
obviously have a plan in mind i just
don't want it to become comic book movie
yeah that's the point is you got to keep
it yeah feeling still like kind of a 70s
like slightly broaching on that you know
heightened territory but still keeping
it really grounded and and icky
anyway yeah we don't have any details on
what this movie would ultimately be but
so i just wanted to throw out there what
i sort of fantasized about what joker
two could possibly turn into so i guess
we'll just wait and see when the
official teaser trailer or plot synopsis
ultimately comes out but guys what would
you want them to do with joker 2
throwing the question to you guys uh
this was just like a fun little fan
theory video i wanted to throw out there
so you can subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and hey we'll catch you
guys soon